hello hey how are you how are you what's
your name
Karina my name is Mark yeah
I'm a photographer I'm a photographer
I want to take your photograph I want to
take your photograph I'm sorry I'm not a
please
my studio is here on 7th Street I'll go
over there yeah I'm ready to take your
photograph me about 20 bucks give me 40
41 yeah okay come on in oh here sir
okay your name is Camille okay Camille
tell me where you're from
oh my name is my name you know where are
you from
oh my laughs what about huh and how long
you been in the United States 82 years
yeah you're very beautiful
well thank you baby tell me your life
story you Oh so my name is my name is
Tanya Tanya Karolina a from Varna I have
38 years living here for 22 years so I
don't have a family because they my
family is the she died for for the
accident so i living here by myself
your family diving into action yeah
where my father and my brother bulla ha
ha
only half my mom what kind of accent huh
I sit in the car or occurs AHA they are
the the bus the bosses they pass today
my family so my family died so you see
you're by yourself
me my mom Hardy yeah
what about I hear you personally have
papers - uh-huh and then what would you
do for work other than what the Skid Row
streets work only this work I don't have
more work somehow you just do this yeah
who's your only job yeah you make good
money then yeah sometimes yeah I depend
so this time not too much money bro
I have a little bit tonight just all
right uh-huh and you're out here whether
it's cold or hot or I mean it's good you
come every day
you know every day sometimes because I'm
scared because I don't want to go to
jail too many police of time ha ha or
you have too many times I do take times
yeah how are you stay in jail
oh not too much because it's the me pay
the BAU me paid my bow my bill
your bails or sometimes company service
so pero it's only for this work
loitering for prostitution I happen not
to much and tell me about the demand may
pick you up your customers or the
customers are the customers they stay I
have another her your customers your
regular customers get older because it's
a nice girl you know yes a nice roast or
the guys pay me so I give me good
service
sometimes I have a problem with in the
street because they with the black
people or you know sometimes the guys
they see when I hates me because it
sometimes 106 for free you know you have
come here only 3 hours every day because
only weekends
Friday Saturday Sunday we come here only
407 3 hours only for 407 407 a.m. ha ha
that's it
interesting hours ha ha before saving
because sometimes a surveying sometimes
data you know yeah I don't worry because
I respect to the children 17 your ha ha
police you know me you know in the
streets hit high because it's the people
of time right I have 20 years working
here yeah does your mom know you do this
huh how does your mom feel about you
doing this
does your mother know yeah yeah she
doesn't know
oh yeah uh-huh but sometimes they have a
somebody like this with my teeth
somebody somebody hits me some reason
I'm hungry this we brought you - uh-huh
like this Oh somebody me cause it's a
nutty 41 have robbed robbed me rob you
grab you by your body my purse so in the
me say you know have man you don't have
money you know so they the guys hits me
tease me so so too much you know we may
stay in the floor and they yeah because
this day I don't have nobody he helped
me nothing you know police not CB
nothing
so the guy's sister hit him I did like
this and they see when I have blood up
for free you know if we say we are
looking for money you know so that's it
only too many problems in the street you
know know it's rough out there
yeah that's in crazy stuff I'm sure you
see more yeah
poor darlin thank you for talking to me
uh-huh very nice to meet you before yeah
thank you to know all my friends
yeah I have I don't have more options
you know for saying my life
I need somebody help me you know
somebody say it say you know what I had
job for you because it's day I have
papers you know I have a say my - day
such as securing everything you know
because to me with my case and
immigration is everything okay aha would
you like to meet a nice man to take care
of you aha yeah that's my life your boss
is annoying my story you know it was
sorry this a little bit I have 38 years
and I have impacts like that yes the
beautiful everything so and looking for
more bigger you want yeah three more
times like this later three more times
yeah and what about down below you
everything surgery or nollie implants my
implants I said AHA I have legs and
everything yes ma'am yeah so
thank you baby everybody you know
anybody should know me customers stay
because I told you is me right here you
know me not taking my name is oh yeah
yeah some girls I know some girls
yeah but [__] you know but ditches so
you tell you very sweet
uh-huh all right thank you for talking
to me okay take it out there take it to
baby this crazy take it for the Tribune
okay yes next time more more my story
okay okay okay
okay baby